[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had set up
various definitions
in the polar coordinate system uh
that can be utilized for the solution of
problems in 2d elasticity
and we had packaged
those those definitions in
a single python file called polar
utilities
now our plan for this lecture is to
utilize
those uh definitions
for the solution of an actual problem
and the route that we will follow
uh is the same as uh in the classic
book uh elasticity by timothy and
goodyear
so first of all what we'll do is
consider a
theta independent a stress function
without referencing to any particular
physical situation
and what we'll do is after discussing
the
form of the stresses we will specialize
our discussion
to a particular axis symmetric problem
which is the problem of the pressure
vessel or the thick walled
pressure vessel so that's the plan let
us proceed so first of all
we have to invoke all the definitions uh
that are present in our polar utilities
package so for that we use this
statement component utilities
import star which will input everything
that we have there
including the command import symbi as
same
so you wait a while while it loads
all right it has loaded so the first
order of business is to actually set up
an area stress function but unlike our
previous class we will not
have a dependence on both r and theta
rather will have a dependence only on r
okay so there will be no theta
dependence this time
so pi is equal to uh
there's a function
but the dependence is now only on r
all right now uh we would like uh
to uh to have uh
[Music]
the form of the of the polar by harmonic
are displayed to us so uh for that we
can just
use the command uh for the function
definition that we had you uh
written down in the in the polar
utilities file
uh so polar bi harmonic is defined there
so
if we if we write this as polar by
harmonic of phi
we're getting this form and please note
that
this is significantly shorter than
the than the polar by harmonic of phi
when phi was dependent on both r and
theta
as was demonstrated in the previous
record video
all right now uh as before
we would like to have these things
displayed uh
in a nicer fashion and for that we
invoke the
the displaying capabilities from ipython
and now we can actually display this in
a
much nicer fashion using the
latest rendering capabilities uh of
jupiter notebook
so uh what i want to display here
is basically the polar by harmonic
itself
for that i need to write this as nabla 4
pi
this will be followed by harmonic of pi
let's see if this thing works all right
that's what i wanted
so this is now displayed very in a very
nice explicit fashion
please note here that this del 4 pi r
that i have that is written
it is just the clear cut
type setting okay so this is the
cosmetic part it is just displayed here
but this is the one that has the actual
mathematical life behind it
anyway so once we have we have these
things
uh what we can do is uh
we can go ahead and try to solve this
equation directly
okay so we we understand that the
equation that we are trying to solve
into the elasticity is the polar by
harmonic
uh or the or the bi-harmonic equation
which is del 4
phi is equal to 0
so if our equation is we set up our
equation
the by harmonic equation has
so everything which is to the left of
the comma is the left hand side of the
equation which is the polar by harmonic
of phi
and just to the right of this comma y
zero so polar by harmonic
phi is set equal to 0 that is the
equation we want to solve
and since this is
a differential equation specifically
a fourth order differential equation
what we are going to use
is the d solve capability
or d solve command within the symbolic
python package
so
let's see what this gives us sim dot d
solve eq
all right so you see how nicely this
solution has been presented to us
okay so this is the solution of the
polar bar or the or the bi-harmonic
equation
okay del 4 phi is equal to 0 now
this is a particularly notable
solution because although we have found
this out
in the context of this
the studio elasticity but especially the
students
of the the first year mtech students
will study another mandatory course
in their second semester advanced
mechanics of solids
and there also in the context of plate
theory
they will encounter another fourth order
equation
where the dependent variable will
certainly not be the any stress function
rather it will be the displacement in
the z direction
but the equation is exactly the same
okay so it is the
fourth fourth order derivative of w
that they have to solve there but the
solution form turns out to be exactly
the same
so this is a rather important equation
this fourth order uh
involving the fourth order derivative
now because we are following the root
of uh or the presentation given in
temushenko and goodyear
we would like to have these this
uh the solution form uh exactly as it is
presented in that book
so there instead of the c1 c2 c3 c4
constants
the constants a b c d are used okay and
in a slightly different order so we'll
follow that book exactly
so we said set up the symbols or define
the symbols first of all
that's done and what we'll do is we'll
set up our file
as
this c4 log r term that is
that is the that is the one involving
the a
so same dot log r plus
b so this c three r square log r term
that is the one involving b
we just manually type it in not that
long
uh the c to r square is c
and finally the constant term c one is d
okay so let's display this once more
uh in the in a nice fashion so
display math
all right so that's exactly what we
wanted
now now that we have in our hand the
form
of this aid stress function we can
immediately find out
the forms for the various stress
components
in this polar coordinate system meaning
to say that we can immediately find out
sigma rr
sigma theta theta and sigma r theta now
please note
that because we have already imported
all the things defined in the polar
utilities file
and if you refer to the previous video
you will see that even the definitions
of
the stress components sigma rr sigma
theta theta and sigma r theta
are already defined there all that i
have to do is just
invoke them with their proper names so
the definition the function definition
for that was sigma
underscore rr or sigma rr5 and what i
will do is
i will assign um the result of that
in this sigma are our variable okay
without the underscore so with the
underscore it is the function call
and without the underscore it is just
the variable name okay that i will
that i'll use to as a as a variable name
for this
for this expression of sigma rr in a
similar fashion for sigma
theta theta
i'll use this for sigma rt of course
use this and now i want to
display this in a nice fashion so again
as usual i use
my ipython display capabilities
[Music]
i can copy this thing because it is
quite repetitive in nature
and for this display i actually use the
theta theta
all right let's try this
okay so this has been displayed very
nicely here and you please note that the
sigma r theta
is indeed coming out to be zero now
uh now this is the part where we
slowly proceed uh to
referencing actual physical situations
because the discussion till now has been
only about
uh utilizing uh all the function
definitions
which are there in the polar utilities
file uh
with the only special thing that we have
done here really
is that instead of a of an area stress
function
that was generally dependent on r and
theta the one that we have taken today
is
just the one that is dependent on r
that's the only special thing that we
have done
and of course we have done this uh
solving of this equation also
other than that we have not done
anything special with regards to any
particular problem now you see because
we are
we are considering an air stress
function which is not dependent on
theta it gives us an indication that
this is perhaps
suitable for accessing kind of problems
okay this is a natural choice uh this
would be a natural choice for an
axometric kind of problem
now accessometric problems can be of
various
different types but
one important thing which we have to
remember about these axis symmetric
problems
is what the the geometry that we are
considering
the the domain the physical domain that
we are considering okay
does that geometry or physical domain
does it contain
the r equal to zero point that is a very
very important consideration to think
about
so all of you have been through your
undergraduate classes
and these are the kinds of
considerations which you have to
keep in mind even though probably you
did not realize it explicitly
but you had to take care of these things
back when you studied
fluid mechanics or for example
uh flow through a pipe okay
so flow through a pipe and flow through
an annular pipe at different
considerations
similarly when you talked about uh
heat transfer okay so for example heat
transfer
in a circular rod or in an
in an annular section so things were
different because
in the in the circular dot the r equal
to zero
was very much part of the domain now
why is it such an important thing to be
concerned about
you note uh to answer that to note you
know this
sigma rr and sigma theta theta terms
okay so
back to 2d elasticity from fluid
mechanics and heat transfer
you note this sigma rr and sigma theta
theta both these terms
they have this 1 by r square and log out
term 1 by r square and log of term
now at r equal to 0 these two terms are
problematic
okay they tend to minus infinity
okay so this log r it tends to minus
infinity this r
1 by r square tends to infinity
now because we are dealing with real
situations and we do not expect our
stress values
to spike um like that to infinite values
what we'll say is that if we consider
a circular domain which does not have
any hole in it okay i repeat
if we consider a circular domain which
does not have any hole in it
where of course that hole would be would
be encompassing that
r equal to zero point then we have to
drop
these terms involving the 1 by r square
and
the log r term okay so
that's what we write so let me convert
this current cell
to a markdown cell so i can put in this
comment
so escape and then i press m to convert
this to a markdown cell
press enter to edit it okay so for a
uh or a domain with
new hole including
with no hole con containing
r equal to zero
the terms involving
a and b must be dropped
okay so that sigma r r and sigma theta
theta
do not give infinite values
so what we'll have is
uh or sigma rr no whole case
okay so let's let's set up a new
variable called sigma r and no hole
all that you have to do is we call the
sigma r
r but then we substitute a is zero
and b is zero okay so let me write that
down
we substitute a as zero and b bl 0
similarly for sigma theta theta no whole
case
a 0 b is 0
and now if we try to display this thing
in a nice fashion
to type out all that but the end result
is
quite visually pleasing so i'll go
through the
to the effort a little bit
i don't have to worry about the sigma r
theta uh
because that is identically zero okay
there are no abc terms there
nothing to worry about for sigma r theta
so let's display this
now we know for sure that of course when
a is 0 and b is 0
we will have only the twice the terms
left i did not have to do all this
symbolic python business for that but i
just wanted to demonstrate
uh once again for the purpose of your
back practice
that how do we go about substituting the
values like this
okay maybe in a different situation you
need to substitute different things
uh so how do we go about doing that all
right
now now that we have this uh we can also
uh next uh considered so so
important thing is that when we are when
you you have a no whole situation
uh and we are we are proceeding from a
uh from an access symmetric concept
consideration where the
air stress function is theta independent
then we end up
with this kind of constant stress values
okay but the situation is going to be
different when we do have
holes present okay so holes including
the r equal to zero
okay so what we do is
we can use this markdown cell
next if we
you have a hole including
r equal to zero
then what is going to happen
is that we can have various different
kinds of solutions
okay then
various different solutions are possible
as a special choice
let us consider the situation
where a is not equal to 0
and t is equal to 0 let us consider this
special situation and you will see the
motivation behind this in a moment
okay we're considering this special
situation so now our focus is on
considering
a a domain a circular domain which does
have a hole inside it
and that hole includes this r equal to
zero so it is concentric about that
uh so concentric without a periphery or
the radius of the
entire domain this whole ah and
as a special choice we are considering
this a not equal to zero b equal to zero
so what happens now
well uh we can go back
to uh this kind of is uh okay
and go back to these
expressions with slight modifications i
won't type them again in order to save
some time
so now we are considering the whole case
and now
i don't have to set my a comma 0
i only need my b comma 0 so b
will be substituted as 0 a will not be
saturated as 0
and i will also
[Music]
display this in a proper fashion
taking care to change the variable names
of course
all right let's display this
now
these particular forms for sigma rr and
sigma theta theta
uh you probably recognize this from your
undergraduate studies
okay so uh i think in most of the
mechanics of solids or mechanics of
materials classes
in undergraduate uh in your
undergraduate studies
this particular chapter is very much
covered access symmetric
of course the root that is uh followed
there is quite different
you you probably
followed the route that you solved the
the displacement field
the second order differential equation
involving the displacement
field in the radial direction and you
probably
ended up with a displacement field
solution
which was like some constant times r
plus another constant divided by r
so if you proceed from there and try to
find out
the expressions of the stresses you will
end up
with this kind of a form where there is
a 1 by r square dependence along with a
constant term
okay now this again this entire
discussion
till now at least in this file it has
been devoid of any reference
to any particular problem now let us see
if we can
actually refer to a particular problem
which
is exactly like like this kind of a
domain
for that i will go to my writing app and
show you this picture
okay so we have these two concentric
circles
and please note that this is like the
end on view of a pressure vessel
this is the kind of pressure vessel
where
the pressure from the outside is denoted
by this p out and the pressure from the
inside
that is this p in i have also denoted
the inner radius as a and the outer
radius as b
so you understand that the material from
which this pressure vessel is made
is present within these two
circles okay this inner circle is
probably filled with some kind of
pressurized liquid
okay so that's the geometry we are
considered uh we are considering
okay so this is an access symmetric
situation it is axis symmetric
because of the geometry as well as
because of the access symmetric nature
of the loading so these two points are
extremely important
you cannot have an access symmetric
problem if
only your geometry is accesometric
whereas your loading is non axis
symmetric so both the loading as well as
the geometry must be axis symmetric for
it to be referred to as an
axisymmetric problem so that those two
conditions are very much satisfied here
because the p out and pn
are very much uniform all along uh the
the peripheries the inner and the outer
peripheries
so we are good okay so this is the kind
of problem we are trying to solve here
so the sigma rr whole and the sigma
theta theta whole
those will be the stresses the radial
and the hoop stresses
in this particular area okay and you
take any point within
uh within this zone at that point you
will have a particular value
of r uh sorry sigma r r and but some
value of sigma theta theta let's find
out what those will be
in response to these boundary conditions
of p
out and p and speaking about boundary
conditions we must be very careful
in setting it up properly so that's what
we'll do
let me go back to the jupiter notebook
file uh
so i'll state the boundary conditions
uh so you all understand that we are now
focusing on this pressure as a problem
okay
so for the boundary conditions
we have let me write this down quickly
here
so sigma r r will be equal to
minus t
in uh
at r equal to a that's what we want
at r equal to a and the same thing
at the outer boundary sigma r r is equal
to
this time minus p out at
r equal to b so these are the boundary
conditions we are looking for
okay so where
in and
the out are the pressures
on the inner and the outer periphery
respectively
okay so with that
stated let us actually define these
symbols p in
and p out
let's also display this so we know that
we have typed everything properly
all right so that's done uh let us also
remember that we need to
set up our a and b uh variables okay the
the inner and the outer region
[Music]
let us adhere to the python community
encouraged best practices of specifying
uh a certain variable to be positive
when we know for sure that
they are indeed positive so a and b are
both radii they are positive quantities
so we state that okay it won't make any
difference but uh
good practice all right so
with these uh out of the way we need to
specify our boundary conditions now
okay so for that what we'll do is we
have to substitute
in this sigma rr whole variables you
please note okay i am going back a
little bit
in this sigma rr whole expression that
we have okay here
what we'll have to do is we have to
substitute r equal to
for this sigma rr whole r equal to a
and then i have to set that to minus p
in
and when i set r equal to
b i have to set this equal to uh minus p
out so that's what i will do
so i'll explicitly set it up
like the lhs and the rhs so i'm first
considering this boundary condition
sigma r
equal to minus p n at r equal to m so
for that sigma r whole uh
subs uh i need to set
r equal to a and the right hand side
of this equation will be minus
v in so that my boundary condition
number one
will be
lhs1 comma rhs
1
let me also display that
next in the same cell i will set up my
uh second boundary condition which is
sigma r equal to minus p
out at r equal to e so again sigma r r
whole hubs
uh rsb substitute rsp and rhs2
is minus p out
so that the actual statement of the
boundary condition
is in this form lhs2 rhs
2 and i'll display this equation also
all right so these are my two equations
and
these are two linear simultaneous
equations involving the unknowns
a and c all that i have to do is use the
symbolic python limb solve command to
solve for this
this we have already done earlier this
kind of uh
of a solution previously for that simply
supported
beam problem uh
and i also need to specify what are the
things i'm solving for here
and please note that i'll assign the
solution
to this variable
now i can display the solution
like this let's see what it gives us
okay so it gives us
the the values of a and c uh
in this package within this solution
variable
now i would like to have these things
explicitly in my hand
okay so instead of displaying it like
this what i'll do is
i'll assign this to
the variable called a solution a as a
solution
and c solution like this okay
it is extremely important that we
maintain the same order of the variables
here okay
so uh the solution uh the
the first element in this solution which
is indexed by this
now by the zero that has to be assigned
to the first thing which is present here
okay so had we placed it like c comma a
there is no restriction which is telling
us that it should be like a comma c we
could very well have written this as c
comma a but if we had done that
then the solution 0 must have must be
assigned
to c solution okay similarly
for the other case okay so now
everything is
fine and
what we can do is we can
we can also display this thing
so that everything is nice clear and
explicit
and just copy this and paste this and
make the appropriate modifications
okay
all right this is the form that i that i
wanted
so all that i have to do now is
substitute these
uh solutions for a and c back in my
expressions of
sigma r r and sigma theta theta and i
will be able to
able to write them down okay so sigma r
are whole but this time
with the solution
term added here
so this will be just sigma rr
whole but where
i am going to substitute
in a the a solution and in c
the c solution so please note this
carefully what i am doing is i am taking
the variable sigma rr whole
and what i am doing is i'm substituting
a solution in a and c solution in c
because in a piece of paper that's
exactly what you would do
similarly for sigma theta theta i don't
have to change anything on the right
hand side
all that it will change here is this
sigma dt okay
and finally i can just display this
nicely
sorry about that
and next for the sigma theta theta
and that's it okay so i can do a little
bit of a
beautification here by writing this as
domain doesn't make any difference of
course
all right so this is the solution
of the pressure vessel problem okay now
with these things set up
okay you can play around
with uh
with this teen and p out maybe you need
a solution
for which p in is perhaps some finite
value but the p
out is zero or maybe p n is zero p
out is some value or any other
combination that you can think of
or face in an actual problem situation
okay so this kind of a general framework
is very much amenable to uh
i mean to modify and to easily test out
the solutions you can also take these
things
uh make them amenable for
our numerical calculations and
and very conveniently for plotting
purposes also
okay so
with this up i have come to an end
of uh of this of this particular
demonstration
so so please note what we have done here
we have we have started out with the
theta independent phi a distress
function
and ultimately we had ended up with a
solution or the pressure vessel problem
the familiar pressure vessel problem
which you had solved by a different
route in your undergraduate days
okay so
i hope this is uh this will be
a good first introduction to the the way
that problems can be solved
uh and in the in the next uh
lectures uh we will address more
involved problems and more interesting
problems
thank you very much